[Music]
hello everybody i'm josh welch president
of film independent and welcome to film
independent presents
i'm very excited to have a conversation
here today with the filmmakers behind
cusp
the fantastic documentary that you've
all just watched
before we begin i want to thank our
our lead sponsor of film independent
presents the hfpa and our partner on all
things film independent vision media
thank you so much and also a huge thanks
to showtime for making this possible
today
[Music]
we're all confused
because there is no
normal
there is no normal and teenage years
i don't know how to describe me i'm not
an adult yet but i'm not a kid anymore
my life is still like i don't know
what's going on yet
my mom always says for like bowling pins
getting knocked down get back up i don't
want people to think i'm easy to run
over
but like i'm only 16 i have forever to
go
let me introduce the co-directors of
cusp isabelle bettencourt and parker
hill isabel and parker thank you so much
for being here today
thanks for having us yeah we're
succeeding here it's great to meet you
and uh let me just start by saying i i
love the film i think it's so
powerful i i i would confess i went into
it
i i'd heard about the film but i
deliberately didn't read about it so i
went in like it was just not knowing
what to expect and i thought it was so
powerful and moving and
surprising and also visually
really beautiful the way it's made so
i'd love to there's a lot of questions i
have for you both about the
content the subject matter of the film
but also your approach to filming and
kind of the aesthetics of the project
um but maybe to kick things off could
you i understand you this originated you
were on a road trip um around the u.s
and sort of stumbled onto your subjects
can you talk a bit about
where you were before well let me
actually back up
you both worked a lot in film and
photography but this is your
first first feature length film is
directors so maybe give us a bit of
background on both of you sort of
professionally and creatively but then
also tell us how how you came to meet
these subjects
yeah is is you got it
oh sure yeah so i um i started
cinematography at nyu and uh came up
kind of through that visual path i
started photography at a young age and
i got really drawn to
kind of observational films and kind of
the humor and observation and seeing
people
you know in their natural environments
and what we can learn about people
through observation
and that kind of led into being
interested in directing and
so after college i was freelancing as a
cinematographer for
documentaries and narrative projects and
then um you know felt ready to tackle a
project of my own and then this kind of
fell into our laps quite literally so
that's um where i was coming at it from
yeah um i went to nyu as well is that's
where izzy and i met um i
spent most of my time in school honestly
like writing and producing it was really
once i graduated um that i like fell in
love with photography and it really just
like changed my whole world it changed
the way i like looked at things changed
who i was as a storyteller i started
really understanding how much you can
how much of a story you can tell just
from a frame and how much of a world and
details you can find um and
coming from a much more scripted
background uh photography was kind of
like my window into documentary and and
observing um
and yeah i mean this whole
road trip kind of came about in a pretty
crazy way my friend was producing a
commercial and like needed pas to return
an rv
from montana to texas in like three days
it was not like a leisurely trip
um
and i reached out to izzy we both have
like a shared interest in kind of like
girl hood photography like photographers
like melissa anne penny lauren
greenfield justine kerland
um and we were also both fascinated with
um
like the american west and this idea of
like american teenagers and girls
um and so the whole trip we were kind of
like looking to photograph like the
american teenage experience
whatever that is uh and we like would go
to a skate park or like a burger joint
in different towns um
and yeah i mean on our last night in
town we were driving through middle of
nowhere texas we were like almost at
austin to return the rv and um it was
like 2 30 in the morning and we pulled
into a gas station and
four girls in a pickup truck come like
barreling in and they were like barefoot
and singing like music was blasting and
they were cracking jokes and it was just
like the epitome of like a free summer
night where like they have no care in
the world and they don't care what time
it is and
they were just bouncing with energy and
so
yeah we were like oh my gosh we have to
talk to them and um we asked to take
their photo and they ended up inviting
us back to their friend's house and it
was just this really like incredible
head like you know getting thrown
headfirst into their world and we were
just so interested and they're like
their energy their freedom they're like
woohoo like it's summer they just were
so carefree um
and they had a lot to say about like
their lives and who they were and what
it was like to be them and
that's kind of how this whole thing
started
were you filming that first night or
were you just hanging out with them kind
of
being with them
uh we were taking stills we weren't like
recording um motion picture yet
wow so and it was it was you said it was
four girls those are your three leads
and then another one of their friends
um
of the four girls literally at the gas
station britney was one of them uh but
when we got back to their friend's house
that night that's where we met autumn
and ilani so it's like a whole friend
group that we were kind of thrown into
wow interesting
um
so
when you decided
to make this as a feature-length dock
i'm curious how like how much time did
you spend with them for the the main
shoot
yeah um well so that first trip we went
down trying to make a short film i think
we were so struck with
kind of the balance between their
teenage freedom and their youth and
their exuberance and then also their
kind of wherewithal and their very
adult way of talking about you know
their lives and so we were like oh let's
go make a 10 you know we're going to go
down for 10 days we're going to shoot a
short film that's like entirely
observational and um we came back and
sort of in watching that footage started
to see that there was a lot more going
on there's a lot more going on with the
girls
we had a bunch of interesting scenes but
it didn't feel like it quite added up to
anything yet and so we decided to go
back but we're still very interested in
the summertime attitude so we wound up
going back in march of that next year so
then we filmed on and off from march
through august 2019.
so we were there for almost you know i
would say a decent amount of that summer
um and that was where the bulk of the
filming was besides maybe a couple
pickup trips while we were uh editing
yeah we shot over 90 days
and i i'd love to hear i mean i'm sure
it evolved over those months but what
the shoots were like i mean it's such a
beautiful observational film you
obviously had incredible access to this
group of friends
and
um did you just
follow them sort of in terms of what
they were doing and where they happened
to be hanging out that day
um and what was it i mean you can't even
the word set is feels wrong here it's a
observational doc but when you're there
with the camera with the girls
what were those sort of
it's obviously very intimate you were up
close and personal not filming from a
distance but what was that like how did
you approach being with them with the
cameras
yeah i mean like the the process of
filming definitely evolved as it went
you know we definitely we were doing
whatever they were doing that day so if
they were like chilling inside watching
grey's anatomy or if they were going
fishing at two in the morning like we
were down for whatever
um but a way that this film really came
together like the the order of how it
unfolded is kind of how we were able
able to film it the first trip we were
um kind of interested in both boys and
girls alike and that's and we were
following boys and girls and that's kind
of how we had access to some of those
like party scenes that are in the film
and
and the more that we learned about what
was actually going on beneath the
surface and some of the darker subject
matter that the girls are dealing with
like we never went back we were never in
the same rooms again after learning
certain things and so like the
the order of how
everything got filmed like hilariously
got
i would say girlier and girlier
literally in the trajectory of filming
um but it was about like trying to
reconcile that like trying to understand
how both things are true at the same
time how like you're at a party and you
might be scared and then the next night
you're like braiding your friend's hair
and
trying to go to mcdonald's and like both
things are true for a teenage girl and
and how do we tell that in a story
um
but yeah i mean in general like we were
just up for whatever they were
doing and uh you know when it's
summertime in texas and it's like 120
degrees outside people don't want to
hang out outside they want to be in the
air conditioning and
there's many a sunset that we're like
come on like let's just go outside it's
beautiful right now we'll go for 10
minutes and then we'll come back into
the air conditioning
but um
no it was uh yeah it was kind of just
like a process that i guess kept
rolling with like growing with our
relationship with them
yeah and i think too like in terms of
intimacy of the camera in the rooms like
we just we're always hanging out and we
always had the camera with us even if we
weren't filming necessarily so we all
got very used to just the fact that
that's how we were in those places and i
mean the days were kind of like roller
coasters like you know it could be super
super boring and then they're like oh
why don't we go to the lake you know
we're like okay i guess we'll go to the
lake with you guys like we almost didn't
go to the lake and then we get to the
lake and autumn you know gets broken up
with at the lake and we were like wow we
almost weren't here like
you just kind of hang on and and see
what happens that day and
you know it can turn around 180 in a
second because i think you know teenage
years there's so much that gets packed
into every day and you're changing so
quickly
and um we just you know we're
kept our eyes open and kept our ears
open and just did whatever they wanted
to do
sorry get ahead i was just going to say
like we were like the right amount of
naive with first-time film directors you
know of like this could be something
let's just keep filming and uh
i think it's funny to think about the
headspace of the earlier trips now
because like after spending so many
months in the edit you're like
it's just so crazy how willing we were
to just spend so much time
doing nothing
right right filming nothing
it does pay off and what were you
shooting on
what what camera
uh we shot on a c300 mark ii and then we
had standard speed prime lenses so
almost the whole movie was shot on a 32
millimeter prime
um which i think really facilitates the
kind of the feeling that you get of
being there it's a very like present
personal lens and we didn't want to we
didn't want to be like a fly on the wall
and feel like we're really zoomed in
you know spying on them we really want
to be within the scenes and really feel
like you're a girl in the room that's
hanging out
that definitely
comes comes through that's that's great
um so with observational verite docs
there's always a question of sort of the
subject's awareness of the camera and
the fact that they know they're being
filmed it's right it's they're not just
living their lives uh
unobserved they're being observed and
i'm curious was there over the course of
your filming did the girls relationship
to you guys and the camera change like
were there moments where
it did feel performative where they were
performing for you or were they just
always kind of
ignoring the camera like how did that
evolve or not evolve over the course of
the shoot
i mean there wasn't yeah i was just
gonna say it's kind of crazy how very
quickly uh they did not care i mean like
on one of the trips like the first
couple days they put on like full faces
of makeup and then they stopped like
pretty quickly and we're like whatever
like you're gonna be here all the time
like i'm not doing this every day
um but yeah it was like pretty quick
that they were just
relatively indifferent i don't know is
you know i think because you know they
met us as photographers and as like
people who were capturing it just became
who we were and like they started
calling us they we had the nickname it
was called film crew and so they would
like call their friend and be like film
crews in town like we're gonna come
through this party like they're gonna
come with and they'd be like okay i'll
film crew you know and then people be
like oh film crew you're back like
it was like kind of
we just became part of you know the
friend group a little bit and we were
just known for the people who had
cameras and it wasn't it felt very
natural and i think the way that we met
them really fed into
that um relationship because
we had come in and cast you know with an
idea who wants to be in our movie i
think it would have felt
very different from like oh we met these
two photographers in the middle of the
night and then we went to a party
and now you know now they're making a
film it's it's very uh it was like a
very organic growth
yeah
i mean it is really
to me one of the most beautiful things
of the film are just the scenes of
just the way they are physically with
each other the all the kids you know but
they're just like hanging out and
draping on each other and fighting and
playing like there's just this like
physicality that feels very
relaxed and and real that's great to
great to see
um i do so
uh parker i think you mentioned sort of
the the darker themes that emerged
in talking with the girls now he wanted
to talk about that i mean they straight
up
they talk about being raped and the
issue of like consent is not real
one of them says they speak very frankly
like why do we get in because the guys
are powerful they're more powerful than
us they they ignore what we say and he's
just okay i lost my virginity it's like
i didn't want to but this is how it
happened and they they talk about with
such frankness
but i'm just like
i don't even know what my question here
is but did that was that emer was that
there from the beginning or did that
emerge when they got more comfortable
and also i'm just curious for you as
filmmakers like what guidelines you had
in place because
they're all underage and they're telling
you about like they're telling you about
crimes and they're telling you about
like
really serious that happened to
them and how do you how do you navigate
that
did you have guidelines okay as
filmmakers were not going to intervene
here this we're just filming this is for
the film or were there points where
you're like
we need to address this or i don't know
you know
become not filmmakers responding to this
yeah i mean on the intervention front
pretty much every anecdote we heard was
in hindsight so it was more
us coming to turn us trying to
understand the stories that we
we were hearing you know as first-time
directors we it was definitely more of
capturing first and then making sense of
it uh in the edit and then in in future
conversations with them
but uh it was kind of like there from
the beginning i mean from that first
trip that we thought this was going to
be a short there were like a couple of
uh once we were back home in new york
and watching the footage and like
removed from the scene there were a
couple of pretty
big scenes one of which is is in the
film
it's like a scene at a party where a
group of kids are talking about
something that happened to a girl and a
guy's like oh well they were both
intoxicated and it's not rape if they're
both intoxicated and
everyone was just so
matter of fact about it and that like
conversation really was like one of the
big reasons why we went back to just ask
like
what's up with that
and how come no one was like
it was just
everyone's energy in the room i mean the
conversation changed really quickly
after but also
like it wasn't
shocking for that to be a subject like a
topic at a party and then they moved on
really quickly and
in asking about it um and also just
trying to understand how everyone's
attitude was like that um
the girls started opening up to us and
kind of sharing uh their experiences and
everyone was just very
matter-of-fact like almost cold about it
and it took us a while
in post and in future conversations with
them to understand that like
to be so
plain spoken about it is to have just
such a knowledge of the experience
whether personally or with your friends
like it was so
widespread it was like a fact of growing
up like yeah this is what you deal with
and it's funny because in the moment it
like
it brushes by really quickly in
conversation and then when you're
separate and because we were filming and
then you you know as filmmakers you're
like watch an interview you're like wait
holy like what
and and it's like so many of these i
feel like follow-up questions came not
in the moment came from like digesting
the footage because
they brush a lot off they like uh
dismiss a lot of what's going on or they
make excuses it was my fault i shouldn't
have let something happen and and it
took us a while to really like
try to get to the heart of uh
how they feel about these topics and and
how
how crazy it is that they're talking
about it in such a a matter of fact kind
of way yeah i mean and we had oh sorry i
was just going to say that i feel like
that's happened so frequently in the
film and it's probably just reflective
of of life
but like
the way conversations are so material or
they'll be like this one topic that's
like you're like and then it just flips
to something else very quickly right so
quickly from like serious to playful to
just and and there's also some great
scenes uh where
somebody says something and the other
person just like is looking but doesn't
say anything there's no verbal response
it's just kind of like
and you know but you capture those
moments of the person's face taking it
in and
not knowing what sort of what they're
thinking about it which is really
visually compelling and
interesting i'm i'm sorry isabel you're
i cut you off i was just going to note
that we had um like a personal code
where you know if we were somewhere and
things felt
you know specifically out of hand we
would
intervene so to speak but we actually
never
needed to use it because it really was
about this like emotional experience and
you know every time we would go to a
party we would realize that like yeah
most parties are like totally innocuous
you know like
there's any given party on any given
weekend you know there might not be
anything that happens that's really
dangerous but there's always the
possibility of danger coming up and what
does that feel like to be at a party
that's otherwise totally innocent
but you know in the back of your head
you know that this can't happen and you
know that it does happen and maybe it's
happened to you or your friends
and so we really wanted to
focus less on the actual details of you
know
the events that have happened to them
and look more at the emotional
experience and their reaction to it
because i think too a lot of times
watching them
disregard things or brush it off or be
sort of neutral about it makes it seem
like they don't understand what they're
talking about but they really do
understand it's just that it's normal
it's just the way that it is right um we
had a conversation with autumn
where we asked we asked her like so how
many of your friends at one point we
didn't fully understand the scope yet we
were like how many of your friends have
had like a non-consensual experience and
she was like oh 100
like that's just like it's not great
it's not good but that is what it is
and um
and that really opened our eyes to
just how much invisible weight that
girls like carry with them everywhere
they go and when they are out having fun
with their friends there is this
this you know this cloud
above them of possibility and great
yeah that experience
um i'd love to hear you talk a bit about
um
the parents um so i will from like kind
of a producer
perspective i'm curious did you have to
get did parents have to sign releases
for you to film their kids as well as
themselves
and
how did you
how did you present this to the parents
and i'm sure you got different reactions
from different parents but what was over
what was overall your working
relationship with the parents as the
film went on
yeah i mean something that's like
uh specific about you know this movie
and speaks to the subject matter is um
when this started
all of the girls that we were filming
were under 18 and all their parents had
to sign releases but all the boys were
actually over 18 and sign their own
releases
um which
speaks to the dynamic a little bit yeah
but yeah i mean the parents have been
involved since day one like we couldn't
you know we wouldn't film a kid without
their parents signing off on it and um
it's i think
because of the organic nature of the way
this came together at first we were like
we just want to make something about
like teenagers in the summer and like
texas and like we want to know what it's
like to be you guys
and i think that really
uh we didn't have an agenda and we were
just like excited to learn and hang out
and the parents were on board with that
and then as you know
our as we were learning what we were
learning and you know our focus shifted
like we would be in constant
conversation like you can't i mean every
time you like walk into autumn's house
you're like catching up with her dad
you're seeing alana you're seeing her
mom like you're you're like we were
always around them so it was just like a
constant conversation
i i loved
the scenes with alani's mom and autumn's
dad were really great but they also
stood out because like they were the
only parents there right i mean that i
recall
but
i i have a 15 year old daughter and i'm
aware like how
at a certain point the parents become
very
incidental right they're like they're
just a barrier to the car that's it yeah
you are just sort of it's like then
charlie brown you know the parents were
like
uh
but is that kind was that reflective of
their lives where the ones who where you
don't see the parents they're just kind
of
absent or not prominent in their
daily life
um
yeah yeah i mean it comes and goes we
also definitely wanted to
show the experience very specifically
from the perspective of the girls which
at times i mean you know i think
it's also it changes throughout the
summer right you're changing so much and
your relationship with your parents is
changing so much and it's so like
volatile and um
you know yeah can be different from a
morning to a night um
and
yeah
yeah yeah
i love the scene
between autumn and her dad when she's
doing the
the picture of texas there's just like
so much affection and warmth in that
it's really beautiful to see the
interplay there
and aulani's mom was amazing and so
revealing of herself in the film like i
mean
those conversations were i was like wow
this is
really amazing access and she was so
open to it
um
was she always sort of on board in that
way like yeah you film whatever you want
not if i'm here you can film me too or
did that kind of grow as she saw what
you were doing
yeah i mean she has definitely been an
open book since the beginning she's
really one of the reasons that this
movie was able to get made she really
like took us under her wing and just
invited us in invited us into her family
but also her world
a lot of these girls she's kind of like
a pseudo-matriarch for a lot of these
girls it's not really featured in the
film too well but like a lot of alani's
friends go to everyone calls her moms
they go to mom's for advice or she'll
help someone out or
get them help if they need or pick them
up from a party if they can't drive or
something like that
and so she uh really like
uh her seal of approval like with other
people her trust in us really made a lot
of people comfortable like right away
and she was just like let's talk what do
you want to know like this is what it's
like to be a woman this is what it's
like to be
um yeah and she was so critical too for
the the generational angle and our
personal understanding of you know we
were still we still are you know young
women-ish young-ish women at the time
and having her to talk to and talk
through the ideas and
and things that we were seeing and her
own experience in her teenage years
really
put um kind of a global spin on
everything yeah it helped us make sense
of the story and
and the angles we were
approaching it from
i wanted to ask a question about
something that's not in the film and i'm
curious if it's not in the film because
the girls just didn't talk about it or
if you chose to just focus the
conversations no more personal material
but
that
politics never came up like they never
talked about trump or
or anything and the fact that it's a
military town you get that at the there
are moments where you see the especially
the opening with i mean not that it's a
military thing but the opening scene
with the guns like it's like gun culture
and
we're in small town texas i'm imagining
that politics is like present in some
form in conversations there but where
the girls just like
they don't talk about donald trump they
don't say right or or did it come up in
ways where you just left it out because
it didn't fit
yeah it never came up we kind of joked
that the girls because also i mean they
were 15 and 16 they couldn't vote yet so
it wasn't really relevant but we kind of
joked that they were apolitical because
they
it just didn't they never thought about
it they never talked about it i mean i
think it speaks more to the you know
public education system in america but
maybe that's for a different movie but
um you know yeah they they weren't
really aware of it and didn't it didn't
really affect their day-to-day yeah
um so
you know when we talk about documentary
the focus is on conversation is always
so much on the subjects of the film or
the social impact of the film but i'd
love to talk also about the artistry of
the film because it's beautifully made
and your both of your backgrounds as
photographers clearly comes through but
can you talk about we talked about this
a little bit in terms of
where the cameras placed in your time up
your lens choice but beyond that like
how how did you guys approach the film
artistically in terms of the aesthetic
and the way you wanted it to look um and
i'm specifically thinking about
well how you definitely how you film the
girls but also
the town the landscape the insert shots
that you have like how did you
approach
that yeah i mean
first of all i think like
texas we kind of view as like an
additional character in the film but
also was one of our like additional
major interests to start telling the
story you know i'm from new york izzy's
from a suburb of la and we both like
love this idea of like
american youth and also like texas i
think you know a lot of it comes from
movies and and photos and uh there's
just like this idea and that um
i mean i guess it's kind of pastoral but
like that's really tied to like this
initial interest and trying to
understand what it's actually like but
they are these girls are largely set
against just this huge amount of
land this huge expanse and you know on
the one hand it's so open but they also
like are going through things that are
very claustrophobic and even though
there's like huge
literal land they're
not that free and you know we always
used some every time we would frame up a
shot where like a girl is walking we
would say like little girl big world but
like you're at an age where you don't
have access to the big world yet you're
just
i mean you can't even sign your own
release you know and and and that
juxtaposition um
but then yeah i mean also like in terms
of texas being a character
we were very drawn to like
animals these girls have like a lot of
animals in their lives every household
has animals and
we found it like really interesting
about how they all cared for their
animals and their pets and like in some
ways they were able to like give love
and take care of something in a way that
they kind of maybe wish they were taken
care of in that way
um
and it really added to this just like
niche natural element um to their lives
and then i mean i as you can i was just
gonna say like on a color level we
wanted it to feel like vibrant and
nostalgic remind you of your own teenage
years have it feel like a memory you
know being a kid being a teenager is
like
one second you're talking about this the
other second you're like rearranging
your room and plucking someone's
eyebrows and and we wanted it to just
like have that energy that was so
rich and vibrant
and i think it's so specific to texas
too like you know we really wanted to
bring out we used colored filters that
parker had used on another shoot just to
like we want it's like how do you get as
close as possible to feeling the like
buttery
you know golden sun of the afternoon or
the like deep magenta purple sunsets
like there really is nowhere like texas
i mean we've spent enough time there now
but um to say that yeah i think it's
like a religion
yeah i mean yeah
if you're in texas you better love texas
but um
and i just think having that be the
backdrop because
you know so much of their world is
taking place indoors or in their rooms
or whatever it is but just outside is
like the most beautiful sunset you've
ever seen and we're like we gotta this
has to be part of it because it's just
it's just they're every day it's like it
adds into what's their their normal you
know
is really gorgeous
you had a couple shots throughout the
film kind of of the main drag where you
see the motel on the left and the
mcdonald's and the dairy queen and it's
like
those shots were so important like they
really give a sense of like okay this is
a very small town this is like a strip
and it starts here and ends here and
there's just this expansive space beyond
it
um
but it also i don't know i love those
shots for some reason they were just
like i was like oh yeah
this is the town this is like
um so my last question is um really
about since the film came out i'm
curious i'm sure the
the girls have seen it and
um did they come to festivals or
have they just seen it you've sent them
links or
i'm curious what i guess my question
regards their reaction to the film and
kind of your sense of the impact the
film had on them like being subjects to
it
must have changed them in some ways i'm
curious what you've seen in that regard
yeah
i mean as two first-time feature
directors we really had like no idea how
to start showing it to them
um and we ended up working with this
incredible woman uh suki madawi she's
like a subject coordinator subject
relations coordinator
it's a new thing it's kind of like how
sets now have like intimacy coordinators
and she really like guided us on like
how do you show subjects of a
documentary the film
and uh she really helped us like map out
how we did it and we ended up showing
each girl like string outs of like
everything she was in before she watched
the whole film so we could like have
conversations about
what it was like to watch themselves if
they were comfortable with everything
also that way as a viewer you're not
like waiting for what else you're in you
like know everything that you're in
and this is all before we picture locked
so this was before we finished our edit
yeah as well
and it was so great it like was just
such an amazing way to start to
introduce them to the difference between
like
the months of us hanging out and filming
and like now this is like a film and a
story and it's not your life it's the
part of your life that we captured um
and it's been really great i mean
watching them like grow
i mean they we filmed when they were
largely 15 16 and now they're 18 19 and
20 and so it's been so amazing watching
them grow and
like start to own the exciting like
they're very inspired by the fact that
they can like help other girls and that
other girls potentially going through
something similar
can feel seen can feel like valid and
feel normal in what they're going
through and and that it's okay to talk
about things i mean
they're so articulate now i wish we
could interview them again because you
know you get older you frame things
differently but um
yeah it's been pretty great we've had
them come to a couple festivals we were
at the austin film festival which was
kind of great it was like a closest
thing we were gonna get like a hometown
screening so a lot of people
that were in the film that aren't just
the three girls like a lot of people
that have been involved over the years
came out which was great
um
and then we recently had a couple of
them come to new york which was very
exciting
they got here they walked in midtown and
they were like it smells bad
i'm like yeah it does welcome
that's great um i said that was my last
question but actually i have one another
one which is that you have amazing
producers on this film i mean chris and
eleanor columbus and uh i forget some of
the others but like big documentary
producers is jamie wolfe
on it yeah yeah as part of the 51 fund
and then wavelength also it's one of our
eps
so how did you at what point did you get
those producers on like we were was it
where you had largely shot and you were
heading into post or how did that come
about
yeah the funny way that this all
happened was that it felt like
the story was happening so quickly in
front of us and when we went back and
started to find the story we realized
that we didn't
have time to stop and and have meetings
and
you know fundraise and stuff so we just
went out of pocket to pay for production
we actually stayed in that
motel that you see on that main drag
i would not recommend it yeah don't
recommend it for me
bugs that might get on your bed but um
so yeah it was it was brutal but um so
we had really largely filmed everything
and begun to edit um before anyone else
joined the team
um but it was incredible when they did
and it was so great to have their
support and it really adding to the team
really made it feel like
you know it had legs and um
that it could really go places so that
was that was amazing
and when did showtime get involved was
that did you sell out of a festival or
were they on board before
uh yeah we premiered at sundance and
then uh sold to showtime shortly after
and was this the 2020 sundance it's what
uh 2021-21 2021 so yeah online pretty
much
yeah
so we did get to go to dallas and see it
at a satellite screening they had
something they're doing it again this
year um which is awesome but uh they're
doing some like pop-up screenings at
independent theaters around the country
um and that really kind of
i i we loved it because people got to
see it that maybe wouldn't have been
able to travel to park city and then we
were able to bring the girls to a
theater in dallas to like do a mini
celebration but we're excited for
festivals to be back
yeah
well congratulations on the film i i
really enjoyed talking to you about it i
hope everyone if if you're watching this
conversation you haven't seen the film
please go watch it on showtime um and i
don't know if you i i have to say i was
fascinated by the boys as well i could
imagine another fact no idea if you're
planning that or interested in it but
the boys perspective i'm like what is
going on here like
you know i mean
so many questions yeah it could
definitely be a whole other movie um but
yeah very easily yes yeah
well thank you so much for taking time
to talk with me and again congrats on
the film
thanks so much yeah we're so great
thanks for having us
[Music]